I Dave Kenickie here with the farm
equipment editor's blog for august 9
2011 just a few weeks ago we conducted a
survey of dealers to see where things
stand with the great EGR versus scr
debate taking place among the farm
equipment manufacturers it was a
follow-up to the survey we took a year
ago on dealers concerns about
introducing exhaust gas recirculation
and selective catalytic reduction engine
technologies to meet tier for interim
requirements you can read about the
survey results in the august issue of
egg equipment intelligence sometimes the
more interesting story comes from the
dealer commentary than from the hard
numbers so we asked dealers the
open-ended question what could
manufacturers do to help ease your and
your customer's concerns about the new
engine technologies far away dealers
most often set educate advertise and
promote that is continue to get the word
out about the new engine technologies
comments included better public
awareness from the manufacturers as
needed educate the customer through
advertising develop and distribute
educational marketing pieces the dealer
commentary was also rife with
frustration mostly with the
contradictory claims coming from the
manufacturers as one dealer put it we
need information to set the record
straight for the customer it does not
need to appear as a sales approach just
the facts please another said run
real-world side-by-side test of tractors
using the different technologies and
compiled maintenance fuel efficiency and
repair data comparisons this should be
done on a farm and not not at the
Nebraska test labs they should be done
more like the real world tests being
done in Europe yet another dealer really
hit it dead on money rollin they need to
do fact-based education about the
different methods which would apply to
all vehicles manufacturers tend to put
their spin on this which in this case is
wrong we all know what the deals are
talking about their real frustration
comes from the confusing claims come
from the manufacturers about the
efficiency maintenance power and other
assorted benefits of their new engines
when all is said and done I don't
believe any of the manufacturers are
misrepresenting the benefits of the new
engines they're simply using selective
data as they're selling points which of
course is the major contributor to
customer confusion it's difficult at
best sorting through all of it in
considering a lot of new farm equipment
costs as much or more than the houses we
live in the snow wonder that farmers may
hesitate when making buying decisions
about something so new several dealers
suggested that manufacturers could
extend the warranties on the new
equipment as a way of demonstrating
confidence in the technology they're
putting out there and to ease customer
concerns but don't hold your breath on
this one as long as the market for new
machinery remains as strong as it has
been manufacturers don't have to do it
you know and I know the real solution to
this challenge as always we'll come down
to the dealer your customers want you to
sort through all the spin and selective
data for them the better you do it the
more confidence the customer will have
in you and the product you're selling
this means you need to know your
competitors products as well as you know
your own thanks for checking in we'll
see you next time
you